I'm a shock mr. I'm and an independent
director on the board of Reliance
Industries Limited the one thing that
needs to be done for job creation is to
enhance the level of education both at
the secondary level as well as in higher
education because this will lead to new
knowledge creation and also when help
entrepreneurship amongst the youth which
has been talked about in this region a
lot in this conference a lot I think
that is the one main thing that needs to
be enhanced of course there they would
be also need for infrastructure projects
projects related to water energy which
will also create a number of jobs thank
you